these expensive looking homes are being
built in an area of Pakistan known as
mini Norway so named because of the
Pakistani workers who made it to Norway
then sent money back home to Gujarat
District their wages helped build these
sprawling houses in Pakistan where the
economy is struggling and the inflation
rate is close to 40 percent
to 750 migrants were feared to be on the
boat which sank in the Mediterranean
last month hundreds of them were from
Pakistan highlighting what's driving
many to attempt a perilous Journey
our kids have to take the risk of trying
to get to Europe what choice do they
have as there aren't any jobs available
that's why we encouraged our nephew and
sent him abroad to earn a living for the
family
grieving relatives blame the government
for leaving them with little option
starvation is the main reason for this
tragic incident which we lost our dear
friend the government is responsible for
what's happening as they are busy with
their dirty politics and it's the poor
who are suffering the most
on it's emerged families paid tens of
thousands of dollars to the people
traffic is involved in the latest
sinking human rights activists say
desperation will continue to fuel
traffic as profits the rise of
unemployment and The Battered economy of
the Pakistan is the one responsible for
these sort of incidents I think we
should request government to dismantle
all the mediums which these human
traffickers have been using it for a
long time to manipulate the dreams of
our young people
police in Pakistan have arrested a
suspected people trafficking gang leader
but making the journey possibly to build
a homes similar to these remains a risk
many are willing to take Michael Apple
Al Jazeera